hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and who is the secret identity
behind Venom in Insomniac Spider-Man 2
the developers have already come out and
said that the Venom in Spider-Man 2 will
not be Edward Brock or someone who has
bonded with Venom in the past and hey
this video was sponsored by Squarespace
the all-in-one platform that makes
launching your own website a breeze but
even so can we still deduce who is
wearing the hungry juice hey that rhymes
well I believe we can in fact I think
that there are a couple of Insomniac
Spider-Man characters that could
actually end up being the Venom that
gets the privilege of fighting not one
but two science nerds in spandex what a
deal so let us explore those
possibilities together my nerd babies
but like always do not forget to hit up
nerd riot.shop to pick up a new
spider-verse inspired shirt today when I
asked you guys on Twitter who you think
Venom will end up being in Spider-Man 2.
the answer that I got the most was
overwhelmingly Harry Osborne and
honestly I get it I mean we first see
the inside of a big ass green science
tube attached to Harry Osborne at the
very end of the first Spider-Man game
after all as part of an attempt by
Norman Osborne to cure his son of his
Austrian syndrome the same terminal
disease that killed Mama Osborne is by
Norman Osborne is a cranky ass all
the time so it wouldn't be too crazy of
a stretch if Venom's familiarity with
Harry Osborne's biology causes him to
ultimately choose to bond with Harry
after Peter inevitably rejects the
Symbiote especially since the Venom
symbiote usually bonds with someone
Peter knows fairly well like you know
Eddie Brock or Flash Thompson however
the one thing that makes me doubt that
Harry Osborne will be Venom in this game
is the little glimpse of Harry Osborne's
personality that we get when we listen
to those messages that he left for Peter
at those old Oscorp research stations
Harry Osborne was basically a saint of a
young man who cared so much about New
York and was super frustrated with the
greedy selfish man that his father was
becoming the Venom symbiote very much
feeds off of human emotions in
particular a person's hatreds so unless
Harry Osborne has some lingering
resentments towards Peter Parker that
have since grown I don't personally
think Harry Osborne will become venom in
the game but it's still possible it was
teased at the end of the game so who
knows but another solid candidate for
Venom in Spider-Man 2 is naturally the
game's other main antagonist Craven the
hunter because as we can see in the
Spider-Man 2 Gameplay trailer Craven is
as immensely strong as he is Savage and
has dedicated his entire existence to
hunting down strong prey and asserting
his dominance over that prey like all
Craven wants to do in life is to find
someone who will Empower as himself just
so we can fight them and give his life
meaning and if you think about it this
is not unlike the Symbiote race in the
comics as Venom's whole entire deal is
also hunting down an equal and asserting
their dominance over that equal through
symbiosis so I can definitely see Venom
taking a strong liking to Craven during
black suit Spider-Man's battles with him
and ultimately merging with Craven when
Peter's anger and hate start to become
too weak to sustain the Symbiote that
would actually work extremely well
thematically because Spider-Man 2
appears to be a story all about teamwork
in particular Peter learning that he
doesn't have to handle being Spider-Man
all alone and that he can rely on other
people like miles and Genki to save the
day Craven bonding with Venom after
Peter finally chooses to embrace miles
as a partner would lead to a
thematically symbolic final battle with
the Spider-Man versus the new Craven
Venom Predator Squad and hey guys it's
2023 if you have a business you should
have a website and if you're gonna have
a website you should be using
Squarespace Squarespace is an all-in-one
platform that provides you with
everything you need to do whatever you
need with your website if you're just
getting started you can build your site
using one of squarespace's professional
website templates they have designs for
every category and use case and they
make it super easy to customize your
look update content and add features to
fit your unique needs and if one of your
needs is merch Squarespace makes it easy
to do that too you can design your
products then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling something besides mer whether
that means physical Goods digital Goods
or a service Squarespace makes it easy
to build your storefront and grow your
business check it out for yourself and
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain and we thank Squarespace again
for sponsoring this video but if not
Harry or Craven I could also see
Insomniac choosing Norman Osborne as
Venom they've obviously teased Norman
Osborne's Origins as the Green Goblin
hard in the first game but Insomniac
could easily alter Norman Osborne's
Green Goblet origin story in this
universe by having Norman first bond
with the Venom symbiote in his first
matchup against Spider-Man and though
yes I am aware of the existence of Venom
president Osborne from spider punch
Universe the comics it was still a
different Universe from 616 and we've
got to remember that Norman Osborne does
appear to be super obsessed with
unlocking the secrets of the darker
parts of Science in this universe it has
applied this dark science to create the
monster that would become Mr negative
knowing that Norm Osborne has been
messing with Dark Matters for so long it
wouldn't be too much of a stretch if
some of that venom goo got on Norman and
began the process of warping his
emotions to hate Spider-Man then after
that we could potentially get some Green
Goblin action in Spider-Man 3 after his
mind is Thoroughly warped however
speaking of Norman Osborne's sketchy
past experiments Martin Lee aka Mr
negative would also make an extremely
fitting surprise Venom in Spider-Man 2
because after Spider-Man stops Mr
negative from enacting his rage against
Norman Osborne Martin Lee just sort of
disappeared with the game not really
getting into what happened to him with
Martin Lee being very familiar with
balancing the darkness within oneself
and wielding Darkness as a weapon I can
definitely see Mr negative strongly
bonding with the Venom symbiote forming
a connection that we really haven't seen
before and with Martin firmly connected
to both Peter and miles's stories as the
murderer of police officer Jefferson
Davis having these two Spider-Man fight
a Venom Mr negative together would be
extremely appropriate and would allow
miles to work through his feelings of
Vengeance and anger that he still have
against Martin Lee you know much like
Peter is dealing with his own anger at
Craven but moving on there's also a
possibility that Venom could secretly be
one of Peter Parker's greatest enemies
Mr Wilson Fisk
now okay though Wilson Fisk has briefly
been Venom in a non-canon Spider-Man
comic in the past you gotta remember
that this dude was
Peter locked him away at the start of
Spider-Man 1 and he's largely been
shoved in the background ever since with
Kingpin being such an influential part
of Peter Parker's story in life as
Spider-Man and his absence basically
triggered all the chaos from the first
game and angry Wilson Fisk bonding with
the Venom symbiote would be a fantastic
way for Wilson to get a round two with
Spider-Man while also upping kingpin's
already formidable strength considerably
anyways with this last one look I know
it's a little bit wild but I'm gonna
need you guys to walk with me here
because Venom could also very much be
the son of J Jonah Jameson the astronaut
J Jonah Jameson the third the only
reason why I say this is because in both
the 90s animated series and in the first
Venom movie with Tom Hardy John Jonah
Jameson the third space shuttle is what
initially brings the Symbiotes to the
planet Earth and since Insomniac has
established in the Miles Morales game
that jj3 exists as an astronaut in this
universe listening to his father's radio
show from a space station orbiting Earth
including him in Spider-Man 2 and then
revealing him to be the Oscorp funded
astronaut that actually he ends up
finding Venom in the first place would
be extremely fitting and if jj3 ends up
hating Spider-Man as much of his dad
over time this would be the perfect
opportunity for the Venom symbiote to
bond with the first human that they saw
and this would sort of be like when jj3
got angry at Spider-Man and these
Spectacular Spider-Man cartoon when he
was Colonel Jupiter
hey Colonel I'm glad you're here
but yeah those are who I believe to be
the top candidates for Venom in
Insomniac Spider-Man 2. who do you guys
think will end up being Venom in that
game let us know in the comment section
down below but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertamed on Twitter if
you guys want to see me tweet some weird
I love you guys so much and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you